ist so absurd alles ich schie da jetzt
gerade mit weiß nicht wie viel Männer
und alle Gefüh sch mit dem Model ab wie
schieach mit mir für die Reportage
schaffe ich undercover als Chatter of
only Fans der Plattform wo man erotische
VÖ und Videos Abonnent kan verkaufen
prlass git sa für 10 Fran bis zu 111 es
Milliarde geschaft was hinter der
Kulisse von Only Fans abgt wüss die
wenigste Agentur Content Creator se
Models und Vertrag und manag i Profil
für me Profit Brut
25000 es W Chatter gesetzt wo im Name
von de Models mit der abonnente
schriebet Ziel auf manipulativ die Art
sexuell Bedürfnis von der Männer maximal
ausnutze zum möglich vielüre Content
verkaufen